flooding threatens thousands of people
in the Midwest after record-setting
reign in the region 12 states report
moderate to severe flooding cities and
towns along the Ohio River face some of
the worst floods in more than 20 years
DeMarco Morgan is in utica Indiana one
of the many towns where people fled the
rising waters tomorrow a good morning
Gail good morning to you just take a
look at this neighborhood right here it
is completely covered in water it
doesn't sit too far away from the
riverfront but emergency responders have
been pretty much working throughout the
night to make rescues and keeping an eye
on those who are choosing to stay around
now let's go and take it at Cincinnati
because this is pretty much the picture
across the Midwest they are dealing with
their own issues there the Ohio River
crusted in Cincinnati and more than 60
feet yesterday and a nearby New Richmond
people needed kayaks and boats to
navigate the flooded streets and
Kentucky record-setting rains sent the
Ohio River spilling into downtown
Louisville flooding in that state killed
two people over the weekend and flood
waters are believed to have killed a 48
year old man in Kalamazoo Michigan parts
of the state will see flooding through
Tuesday and in Indiana it is experience
it again record-setting flooding a water
[ __ ] start to recede within the next
couple of days but we are expecting more
rain on Wednesday which could mean more
flooding Nora
all right DeMarco thank you